Oh what is going on YouTube now I've
heard a lot of fat before from the
comments talking about where the lenses
in my glasses when Miller the most beer
hipster history you guys I look Gladys
my whole life to tell the kid I've been
blind as a bat but yes I got tired the
Sharat I don't want to go with him fool
you guys tell you guys that in ten
classes but I thought LASIK and it costs
me a hefty penny I actually thought my
eyes were had a negative nine around
there and then when I actually got my
eyes checked it turns out that I was
like a negative 10 negative lemon in my
eyes so I believe you're legally blind
around the negative eight simply what
that means is if you were not gone to
the altercation you're slapped in the
face I'm a glass of cool off basically
I'm done son pick my ass up do it did
you know what it was just I was in the
heat of the moment I just wanna come on
back in the day remember when you were
growing up glasses were probably wanted
to get his things on earth
anyway glasses people say jokes like oh
my god yes my four eyes three or four
eyes over the go oh I know what you
gonna call me that's good whatever okay
it seems like glasses are the coolest
thing to do it's like the hipster thing
I don't know who started this trend
about glasses being cool but where were
you 12 years ago when I was getting
dumped into a toilet in the wet you put
a call from a national like this I'm
here what you say you call me hips all
you want it doesn't matter because I
picked left's my whole life that's hard
for me to live without them in fact I
think I look weird to be out of the Jews
bad enough everybody says I look like
side this does not help Oh [ __ ] from
stuff I just wanted to go ahead and let
you guys think on that and plus I got
some exciting news for y'all so remember
this thing I used to have comb the
peoples hater so what does the people
hate the UN but those of you out there
that feel like you always wanted to tell
something to somebody what you want it
to like really let them know how you
felt about the situation you let me know
you go ahead and put all the wrong
to you and let me know in a short one
paragraph okay short one paragraph about
what that person did you and I'll go
ahead not just it and see what comes up
here the end that you're not wrong how
do you go ahead and do this you're gonna
go ahead and go on to my facebook fan
page and drop all the stories in there
and so remember it only has to be one
paragraph if it goes over I just might
not read it I can't breathe I'm not that
smart
oh so basically if you have to go ahead
and submit your people story by the 11th
of February and on the 18th I'm gonna go
ahead and drop it down nakamoto look so
remember what you have to do is go ahead
and like my facebook fan page and tell
me your story in one paragraph and then
the people say today is about to go down
so do that five February 11 and on
February 18th your stories will be
posted up on my YouTube video page but I
will go ahead and there you can smack
down what this is a weird ending I need
to know how to end my videos super super
excited tell y'all know culturally all
across the world there was one word that
we all connect with and it ain't love is
the word free what's your favorite price
399 sucker guess what my Asian brothers
and sisters and non-asians mother
sisters are like Verizon Wireless is
doing a special promotion to celebrate
Lunar New Year check it out and miss
Academy if you go into select Verizon
Wireless retail stores in between
February 9th and February 11th and sign
up for a new or renew your two-year
contract with Verizon Wireless you will
receive a lucky bag which contains a
free accessory bundle that's no I guess
what a limited amount of these get will
also contain a lucky gimmick and you
guys might wonder which Verizon Wireless
retail stores are participating in this
you can go in and find that out at this
limo right here oh and check it out by
the way if you guys miss that huge show
that just happened last weekend with me
kina grannis Nikki Sun new heights Jason
Chen and Jane
so the 2013 Lunar New Year celebration
was actually presented by horizon virus
which goes to show how much nut they got
through the Asian community so I want
you guys to go ahead and really check
out this video that's about to pop up at
the end and going to keep it down and
I'm trusting you guys won't be
disappointed